hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Michel we're about
to click on this button that says truth
I don't know what's gonna do but it was
a big question mark before so I'm
various enter this girl what oh no do I
have to play through the whole game
again no it was what's her name
so man sabirah his Samantha alright
congratulations on beating the game did
you enjoy me so yes now then a new story
awaits you one you have thus far yet to
see none know what may happen
are you prepared samantha is prepared
then allow me to guide you welcome to a
new story okay so alright then strange
where'd it go hello um what is it
Misao she spoke to me ah just dropped a
contact I think it's around here
somewhere
Misao um I'll look with you friends
thanks
Misao never got much attention but she
was really nice
why would a girl like that do such
things do what in Samantha uh hmm
someone's calling me I've heard it
before
Oh what am i what am i doing out here
huh
where am I I was just in class love's
nodding off in class and what happened
Samantha uh only Kawara is that you only
Guara mr. Oni Guevara okay I'm still
another world game saved indeed yes okay
all right oh hello go see goos good to
know that you're lining the streets oh
this is ah mr. Rhodey Guevara
it's been a while Samantha ah mr. Oni
Guevara why the heck did you call me
here truth is I thought I would offer
liberation to the spirit said been
sacrificed
yoshino and the rest you can do that why
that girl me Sal went a bit too far
indeed what they did is unforgivable but
her death was not their fault they
suffer just as much I think it took rule
to allow that suffering to continue as
such I have decided I will release their
spirits if you do that will everyone
come back
that's impossible sadly but if their
will to live is strong enough they could
possibly be born again will you try to
save them Samantha ah I leave the choice
up to you why me why not Toma he's
friends with everyone I am confident you
are the only one who can save them no
others would be able to mr. Rhodey awara
I have high hopes for you
but wait okay so there's a weird head in
the corner that's a thing I'm actually
my mind is like going what
named Samantha uh I can't remember if
thousand why is it wet I can't remember
if those actually the name uh no yeah
let's not go touching weird things just
yet oh it's a safe point how quaint I
will do that then I'm gonna leave the
same but I can might be able to see what
something else does but I'm gonna check
these out
kudos Grave kudos to Kudo for dying
first
alright what do we got here oh yeah use
childhood friends okay that's right
sniffle sniffle what's wrong me Sal
Takeshi kept teasing me not again hey
there there I'll take care of Takeshi
don't cry okay let's go home I'll
protect you on the way so why did Michel
hate this guy again mmm-hmm I mean he
confessed his love and she kind of ran
him over with a car you were so kind
then oh but you changed okay wait wait
pan-pan
why are you getting ahead of me let's go
home together please Hey you've been
acting so strange why are you ignoring
me get some sense you're annoying me
sorry I know I'm kind of a bother but I
try not to be I'll try to do things on
my own I promise I won't bother you so
so annoying it I never talk to me again
what a dick I am why God that sans poor
girl Umi Sal let me see you for a sec No
why not you giving me lip ow
you know what'll happen yes
Oh Kudo you're such a douche you
abandoned me I trusted you I won't
forgive you
so okay you ran him over with the car
where is this other world darkness gato
hello
stop it already die die already
spineless die die die forgive me
Misao died in a fire burn in hell the
meat stop stop I hate you died a virgin
okay that's me that's just cruel why you
gotta give the low blows kudos say with
me - no is uses died already
Misao please stop I'm sorry so sorry
dude oh please come back with me forgive
me there's no point in grieving Foley
I've been quicker it's my fault oh my
fault no it's not your fault but it is
me so loathe me this is utmost proof of
that saw me to blame Kudo
no these girls are me Sal disillusions
born from the darkness of your heart
What nonsense what do you base that on
because me Sal is so nice she wouldn't
say these things don't you know that
yourself you're right me Sal
lets me say aha No is it me sale have I
been saying it wrong the whole damn game
coop Doh me say Oh ding Missa Kudo
calling me by my first name
you haven't called me that in so long
I'm sorry Kudo no I should be
apologizing it's my fault you it's fine
I don't hate you
why didn't I abandon you yes it was very
lonely
I suffered like I was going to die but I
knew how you felt Kudo
he's just lacked courage I knew you were
always thinking of me and that made me
happy regardless he's a help thank you
for thinking of me I love you too Kudo
Misa
they say oh I don't know is his rate was
that me Sal who appeared in front of
Kudo the real one I wonder if that means
I was just an illusion of kudos to
probably at least he's at peace so
that's some point yeah yeah what is that
was that oh it's a Kudo baby
Oh gross yeah what's over here be
careful the spirit of the man who killed
me so sealed up ahead okay you don't
want to mess with that one just yet yo
she knows grave touch it yes of course
okay she's gonna have a tough time
forgiving this one I don't have any
items it ah open nice out don't be a bad
girl maybe if you'd be good I'll let you
out oh no stop stay away open all right
stop help I'm scared it's dirty it hurts
it's gross ow ow ow whoa hello never
forgive okay already then God good to
know never forgive forgive me forgive me
me sounds oh oh boy just still gross Wow
alright then someone's having fun over
here
yeah help you can't get away with Villa
you did the meats out Yoshi no this is
punishment but I know you've suffered
yourself shop for you you shall won't
you shop I understand how you feel but
you see no regrets it - nope ok I guess
it didn't work only I could find
something to stop me shall with baby uhh
is it what I didn't read god I didn't
read what it was
Oh salt oh I was just salt in the urinal
no I can't do something so awful a
sprinkler with salt better think of
something else
oh I'm convinced now the back oh I see
I'm getting different items ok alright
look money alright so the bat okay
alright then yoshino who doesn't look
like she can speak sniff forgive me do
me yoshino it's fine now no nose out
sniff Yoshino I hope this has taught you
not to be a bully
I won't I swear I won't forgive me
I'm sure me Sal will let's head back
together why hey how's it going why are
you getting in my way I thought you
wanted to help me I thought you were my
one friend yes I've always been your
friend misael but letting you do this
wouldn't be helping you at all what are
you me cell you haven't passed on yet if
you keep doing this you'll never be able
to shut up listen ma'am
will he doing this really clear up your
heart quiet of course it won't if it did
you would already would have ascended
shut up shut up shut up stop this em
you're just being vengeful I don't want
to see you like that science okie dokie
um
all right so there's just one more and
then the final one and in all honesty
I'm gonna save that until the next one
because I just don't have enough time
for this one here so thank you all so
much for watching click the in today's
more videos that I've done we'll finish
this up in the next video thanks again
and as always I will see you [ __ ]
then not good no goodness baby Gus oh I
see a woman